hidey ho rejectos we're gonna watch
ourselves some brooklyn nine-nine today
guys thank you so much for clicking on
this video i mean the world if you could
just go ahead and hit that like button
helps us out the most also subscribe and
click that notification bell get
notified when our reaction for the next
brooklyn nine-nine is up it's looking
like these are gonna be mondays from
here on out this is much easier to
manage that way to be totally honest
with you guys and uh yeah full-length
watch launch we stick with the time
quote from brooklyn 99 or over at our
patreon page thanks to all who have
become super rejects so far yeah thanks
for uh everyone who's been watching
along with us this entire time it's
awesome thanks to the boys of prepper
for helping us out down these highlights
too let's get to it
someone's dropping off a care package
for mom ew no
it's the stuff that sophia left in my
apartment and i just want to walk up to
sofia's slapper in the face and say girl
you messed up you need to destroy that
stuff you want me to crush that big box
into a little ball with my bare hands
i want to see that you need to embrace
the pain so you can get through it you
need catharsis
charges right you need a cathart
cathart all over the place that is a
great point guys thank you you know who
would appreciate that a lot of sofia i'm
gonna text her i'm gonna take that phone
now jake i'd like to see you try
but i promise you the best thing for me
right now is to text sophia my phone
thank you fancy
why isn't she written back yet god this
feels terrible you two could have
stopped this but you didn't you monsters
must really loved her off screen
yeah
homeland security runs a multi-agency
counter-terrorism drill the team from
the deal ah it's the coffee cup from
hawkeye thanks to our stellar scores at
last year's tactical village nine-nine
they want us to fill in we are the only
non-federal agency ever invited to this
event this is a huge opportunity and we
are going to nail it
this drill couldn't have come at a
better time i'm going to throw myself
into it and focus solely on getting a
win and not whether or not sophia is
texting me back which she hasn't in case
anyone was wondering nine-nine yeah oh
that's tough
santiago diaz before you go both of you
requested to have this saturday off but
i need one of you to work oh i could
take that shift well last time you
worked at saturday you watched cartoons
the entire time well that's when you're
on
i can't reschedule i have tickets to a
ted talk on power poses and getting what
you want by using your body uh-oh i hope
it doesn't get too sexual uh-oh i hope
it doesn't get too sexual title of your
sex tape
it's been a while since we've had a sex
tape time
if you told me what you were really
doing i'd consider changing my plans but
you didn't so
i'm getting saturday off
are you trying to power pose me i don't
know maybe i'm supposed to be sitting in
a chair this is why i need to see the
talk
you know how i've been defying all
expectations by going back to school i
always knew you had it in you can't you
just be blown away by me this
personality test for my psych class i
was hoping to wow my professor with a
genuine psycho like amy or hitchcock or
charles would be great i'm not a psycho
but i could take your test
i do need to warn you that the results
can be a little unflattering it's okay
i'm no stranger to unflattering test
results
your blood pressure's normal
normal
take it again
just to be clear though it is possible
to get a result that shows
no flaws i guess good good
can't wait to begin
[Laughter]
jake peralta nypd pleasure to meet a
colleague colleague
ah cruel
terrorists have stormed the capital
trust bank building and have taken
hostages
oh cool trick i don't have a ton of free
time to practice high-fiving
you just made fun of us for that for
practicing that's the first time we've
ever tried it
an nypd helicopter snipers helicopter
sniper says here you will be our
hostages
oh just want us to lie on the ground and
do nothing like a bunch of losers yes
precisely no jackpot
they didn't rehearse that all right you
know what screw this i'm not gonna just
sit here like a loser boyle free me then
i'll free you we're fighting back
okay charles our hands are tied so we're
gonna have to use our mouths smart with
the tape down with my saliva until he
could slip right out
what body of water do you most identify
with a lake b river c ocean oh they
can't be serious of course i choose
ocean
oh
you got category i9 c3 g6 i9 c3 g6 is
that as good as it sounds you have a
robust sense of self and are well suited
to leadership positions
tenacity yes i suppose that's accurate
they do call me tenacious raid down at
the country club because for the passing
years i've been suing them for
discrimination
we got the same score it's just crazy
how accurate this thing is yes
crazy oh i wanted to be clear i had no
pardon this no offense but you are a
huge waste of muscles okay boyle there's
two guards outside the store we need
their guns you know what to do beat them
up pretend to be sick and lure them in
here right you're charles there we go
gosh
what's wrong i have seasonal affective
disorder what
the hell
we're fighting back you terrorist crap
sack
thank you for including us in this event
[Music]
oh you're dead see you later losers
again opportunity of a lifetime just a
real positive experience
i think it's awesome we're taking this
into our hands yeah
door kick what's up dude is it lunch
time is the drill over we're freeing you
guys jake can you hear me is it lunch
time
it's time it's 10 30 in the morning no
wonder i'm starving this is just an hour
and a half we are hostages no longer
it was really meant to rip off the whole
thing but i say we go with it come with
me
hose
yes
42 santiago jake this is great i shot a
guy in the face he is so mad at me nice
it's a regular paint bath like bubble
bath no like blood bath yeah all right
meet in the basement here we go
yeah
okay me and boyle took down six rosa and
amy got 14. hitchcock and scully we're
killed immediately yeah we're dead no
he's not him
drop him right now it's over you lost
drop them now or this nah man it did
crap
i also couldn't spend another second
listening to those atf wads bitching mom
leave it to the nypd to screw up being
hostages i thought cops love to sit
around on their fat asses all day and do
nothing that's it
[Applause]
look i'm proud to be a cop this drill is
over let's get the hell out of here
drinks on me night night yeah
[Applause]
nypd you're supposed to be hostages
supposed to be but we rose up and took
down the terrorists that's right we're
the bad guys now is this some sort of
game to you does this sound like a game
i am a terrorist leader my name is
francis
also i'm related to jeremy irons from
the third one okay so it is a game
nakatobi yes we're not on the same level
and apparently you're at the level that
can't handle us you trying to goad me
peralta cause i'm in charge here and i
don't have to engage with mall cops
but i will
this drill doesn't end until one of us
is dead one large pizza with fennel
sausage brick oven otherwise it's sog
city and skully needs some gas and ex
extra strength to a ball
okay so a fight to the death
pizza
and gasoline
paintball the hostage every 15 minutes
get yourself a deal gruber
get us those demands we'll be waiting
we're not waiting one second those
demands were a ruse they were i really
need that gasoline i think there was
some dairy in the cheesecake that i hate
from breakfast
we're gonna take the fight to them like
some waddling ducks if the waddling was
super fast and cool like some boss ass
penguins yes
[Laughter]
yes sir
round cookies and square blondies you
opt for the cookie i'm whimsical but i'm
not a lunatic but butter eggs flour
sugar baking soda chocolate salt vanilla
the only salient difference the shape
you're trying to get me bumped out of
i-9 seeds
do you know how many basic [ __ ] would
kill
to have the same personality as me we're
not exactly cut from the same cloth
apparently not i of course am exotic
silk whereas you sir are snake skin it's
a box of shapes and it contains only the
truth
what the hell 9 8 saturday's mine you
said body count you didn't say whose
body boom power pose oh
no
damn boyle you can shoot yeah
oh damn boyle kendrick
come out
it's just you and me
i'm out of ammo be cool well well well
don't buy hello agent no he's not good
don't buy it
any last words just don't shoot me in
the face i got a date tonight i don't
want to puff up i'm already 10 pounds
heavier than the picture she saw okay
those are your last words because i'm
about to shoot you
what die-hard
gun tape to the back all these die hard
references gave me the idea
i got john mcclane
that is so much worse than any paintball
oh
i'm probably 20 less devastated than i
would have been this morning that's next
to you guys
i cathartic you could thought it hard we
should all be so lucky i don't deserve
to be an i9 c3 g6 i should be an i9 c3
g4 or an i8 c5 g3 or even an i7 c7 g8 or
oh my god
you're tenacious you're strong
you're a great leader and most
importantly any basic [ __ ] would be
lucky to be like you she puts people
down all the time constantly
you are now in charge of all scheduling
decisions and budget tracking no you can
do it trust me from one i9 c3 g6 to
another
it's crazy how much he flirts with me
the dinner with my parents on saturday
is
to introduce them to marcus what why
didn't you just tell me i didn't know
stuff was getting that serious yeah it's
very embarrassing having feelings
yeah i feel you dropping this off for
sophia perez
oh no you don't have to call her i'll
just leave it here with you
as she walks in hi uh sorry i didn't
text you back
thanks for bringing my things i'll see
you in corgi
bye
tell me if she turns back for one last
look oh
oh she turned off
did she turn
[Music]
[Laughter]
sorry buddy
we're all rooting for you
oh man that sucks
that sucks
god i never want to go through a breakup
again
yeah breakups ain't fun they suck
they suck and he looks back to pretty
healthy reasonable level yeah reasonable
time frame
because
man
real life
get ready for a six-month dive yeah
that's what it turns into every single
time
it's the hard part breakup not like
nearly three six months yeah
it's pain in the ass mm-hmm it's hard to
detox yourself from another human
you know
let's go through every one of our
burritos yeah
the emotional anguish and our own need
to cathart
i mean usually people try to sleep with
other people
in order to get over it because that's
what works yeah to feel validated and
ordered like i'm still attractive yeah
and i could put my sexual attention
elsewhere and feel comforted
i never succeeded at such a prospect
it's okay
now i'm in love
yeah
aren't you bummed
that's gonna leave me i can feel it
tonight
especially after this episode
like dark poor tense all i was thinking
the whole time was oh it's too real
to a premonition i'm having in this
moment yes
it was a fun episode very fun episode i
love the i love the games yeah every
sitcom you know the sitcoms it's the
games
the games are where it's at you know the
network of guest stars to come and foil
our heroes they never have like a guest
star
correct me if i'm wrong
but so far whenever they meet someone
from another department it's always like
mockery or antagonistic or competitive
it's never like
we're getting along yeah we're doing
this together thank god i've been
wanting to work with you yeah yeah yeah
at the bottom of the totem pole and
everyone always looks down at them yeah
you know and they're always dealing with
like egotistical people
whereas like jake is like falsely
narcissistic
without reason to be for real yeah yeah
i would be interested to see if they do
to change that because i mean you get
kind of two flavors then pontiac
bandages
yeah welfare i mean but uh even he is
sort of always yeah one-upping it's it's
a definite competition even still yeah
but that one at least has the the the
opposite flavor underneath of ah but
these guys are made to be buds whereas
yeah every other one is either that it's
like ed helms where it's like oh this
sounds like it's gonna be silly but he
has a way over inflated opinion of
himself or it's like homeland security
where they're freaking homeland security
yeah jason crawl right uh
nick nick crawford that girl nick
crawford yeah
he usually has like long hair now right
longer yeah i feel like he looks a
little different not not like long long
but yeah uh he's a funny ass dude that
one yeah he's a funny guy people love
that big mouth
this makes the show work so well the
heart they decided to shoot a bunch of
people rebel against the game all in the
name of making sure jake can distract
himself
let some paint out he could go to the
gym
it could work out yeah but he needs the
narrative you know how much jake loves a
character and slipping into a situation
is it amy single now
i think so yeah cause uh her and teddy
did not work out
what's he doing teddy
who knows teddy oh let's see he
take two what's she doing i don't know
man i mean maybe after this episode
keeping an eye on all jakey's over here
cause uh i mean that's the thing about
the sofia storyline and that's what i've
started to realize about stuff like this
where it's like okay and i'm watching
you know like there are various other
shows that do this uh but you know it's
like you bring in a female guest star to
be the romantic interest that's supposed
to add tension to the will they won't
they of the greater overall ensemble of
who's supposed to get together and i
wish that shows would do more to
actually like really embrace
uh the involvement of those characters
like i thought it was neat here that she
actually showed up for that one scene
and they make you know a really fun bit
out of jake's just obsession
over getting that text back but uh but
it does feel like there could be more
just to make that feel like it's more
than a device to
create that tension
yeah sure sure sure
but even so i mean it was a
i'm not really craving more of her
no i'm not either but i'm saying like i
feel like they could have had the
opportunity to make
like they were charming together and you
know like evil angora actually she's fun
to watch but hey at the same time it's
not a character where i'm like oh man
i'm bummed you know that she's not gonna
be with him anymore and i feel like if
they had maybe gone broader or gone more
in depth with both endearing us to their
relationship and also you know giving
her funny stuff to do
uh but that's not like something that's
like essential it's just something i've
come to sort of
feel
over so many shows is like ah it would
be nice if i wasn't so aware that this
is just a device yeah you know but uh
but yeah like the whole kind of thing
they've made out of it for him to deal
with is really funny and like yeah that
whole like there was a lot of really
great just like timing based gags across
this episode like that whole bit at the
end
she turning around is she turning around
and even like you know when they're
goading terry into trying to join them
and stuff like that and they're mutiny
there's a lot of good like
uh yeah
le uh timing based back and forth like
you know uh body language based uh humor
and stuff like that and then we have
gina and terry gina and uh and holt gina
and terry did terry
same thing right
yeah gina two hours of sleep people
have tried to look awake this whole time
yeah rosa and uh
and terry a little bit tempted to close
my eyes for most of this it's okay it's
okay that's fun though unfortunately
it's easy to stay awake for brooklyn
yeah and that was a very fun
sub ga like a b plot you know of them
like have we done i know we have a
couple but i feel like we don't as often
do like it's just gina and holt because
they're so opposite in a lot of ways and
i like that they
zeroed directly in on that
well he's like the most direct and
straightforward
robust yeah whereas she's a such a wild
card yeah while being sort of direct and
straightforward
well she has like uh a different type of
leadership ability i do think she is a
leader in some ways
of like she doesn't
she does things her own way
she she sticks to her own lens about
life
and uh
she doesn't really care about other
people's opinions
you know
yeah it's a very confident person that
gina lynnetti she does talk down to a
lot of people yeah she diminishes most
everybody inside that's her character
yeah paul was saying that i'm like she
talks about people all the time yeah
that's that's what's in the mix
that was how cruel she is yeah
and i mean i appreciate that they have
nuanced they they you know over time
have nuanced her slightly beyond that
but that's still pretty core the the
bedrock of that character yeah for sure
immediately expect a thousand percent
all right guys well this is another fun
one brooklyn nine-nine show is always
sort of goddamn consistent there's only
been like one episode maybe i haven't
really enjoyed i always look forward to
these so consistent guys leave your
thoughts down below thanks for being
here
we should do a pizza
fox if there's anybody out there who i
know
can rock a power pose and use it
to inflict or gain your will it's
definitely you you have such confidence
but also like the characters in this
episode you also march to the beat of
your own drum at least in our
experiences you know you have your own
tone of voice even through the comments
you leave on patreon like i can hear
somebody talking true and i appreciate
that about you plus i imagine that if
you were thrust into a kind of situation
like this you know some kind of
simulated hostage scenario you could
probably take control and lead your way
to winning and i would follow you yeah
you know without question whether or not
you empower or diminish me i am putty
and you're i'm a tool for you to point
and tell me what's on you yeah so uh fox
thank you for your continued loving
support thank you yeah it's nice to see
your name pop up whenever it pops up
thank you
you'll float away for a little while
you'll leave and i'm like where's fox
been and then pretty soon there you go
you come right back
appreciate your love hope you're doing
well in the year of our lord 2022
and uh we'll catch you
next month yeah thank you be well
we're done
[Music]